[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance no American should again
stand during the national anthem until
our rights to protest are no longer
being threatened by this dictator in
presidents clothing no athlete should
stand no fan no one I will not stand
you should not either the flag is our
dearest symbol it is the representation
of our nation it is the emblem of our
freedoms and Donald Trump is an enemy to
all these things he has now shown his
true self to us all if you protest the
death of innocent civilians you should
be fired if you protest him you should
be fired if you protest you should be
fired we will not stand for this
literally we will not stand these are
the statements that dictators make now
not tomorrow not later not perhaps not
reminiscent of these are the statements
that dictators make we have reached that
terrible moment in the history of this
country when the pretense has been
stripped away and the government is for
all intents and purposes erasing the
First Amendment Congress shall make no
law abridging the freedom of speech or
of the press or the right of the people
peaceably to assemble and to petition
the government for a redress of
grievances with a series of ever more
shrill ever more hysterical tweets
Donald Trump has abridge the freedom of
speech Donald Trump has abridge the
freedom of the press Donald Trump has
abridge the right of the people to
peaceably assemble Donald Trump has
abridged the right of the people to
petition for a redress of grievances
Donald Trump has demanded through his
press secretary that a sports
broadcaster be fired for being an
American
Donald Trump has demanded from his own
venal mouth that professional athletes
be fired for being Americans Donald
Trump has demanded that those
corporations doing that most American of
things making money should be punished
financially for employing Americans who
are exercising their rights under the
Constitution we will stop him we will
not
and for him Trump has escalated this
conflict between the America we love and
for whom our Patriots died at his
American dictatorship this was once only
about African American athletes silently
protesting militarized uncontrolled
police aggression against other African
Americans this was once only about these
athletes and what happened to one of
them Colin Kaepernick and something that
smells and looks and feels like a
blacklist
this was once only about these athletes
and Kaepernick and the KKK and Nazis and
terrorists at Charlotte's ville with
whom Trump empathized and who carried
the symbol of true disrespect to the
American flag the Confederate flag and
noticed Sunday Trump retweeted this call
to boycott the entire National Football
League superimposed on a pattern far too
eerily similar to the Confederate flag
but this weekend past Trump made this
far far worse he made it about all of us
this weekend past Trump made it about
you you and your right to protest to
protest during the anthem or to protest
against protesting during the anthem you
and your right to protest to protest
that black lives matter or to protest
against black lives matter you and your
right to protest to protest against him
or to protest for him under Trump in the
United States of America you do not now
have the right to call him what his own
words and action tell you who he is
if you do he may have one of his minions
go on live television and call for your
employer to fire you or for your
employer to be financially penalized
under Trump in the United States of
America you do not now have the right to
protest against him or protest against
the racist X sheriffs he coddles or
protest against violence against African
Americans or protest against the
exponentially growing government
endorsed racial prejudice and for all
intents and purposes government endorsed
move back towards Jim Crow under Trump
in the United States of America you do
not now have the right to protest
symbolically non-violently respectfully
under Trump in the United States of
America whether you are for him or
against him whether you were a
corporation or an individual you now do
not have the right to earn a profit or a
living unless he says so under Trump in
the United States of America as his
phony voting Commission still schemes
and plots you may soon not have the
right to protest by voting against him
the athletes he insulted this weekend
and face it to this point the athletes
and the sportscaster and the others at
whom he has directed his dictators rage
have been African Americans all of them
and all of them of other Heritage's and
all the fans and all the media should
not stand for this should not stand for
him and during the national anthem
should not stand there will leave you
with three reminders Trump is not doing
this out of some kind of twisted
patriotism this is calculated it is
mercenary it is cynical and most
importantly it is utterly hypocritical
Obama's o7 speech which at daily Carr
just released not only shows that Obama
is a racist but also how the press
always covers for him the Trump of 2017
would have had his press secretary call
for the Trump of 2012 to lose his
television show his job in his
livelihood and worse still if a player
wants the privilege of making millions
of dollars in the NFL or other leagues
he or she should not be allowed to
disrespect our great American flag or
country and should stand for the
national anthem if not you're fired
find something else to do fired if you
disrespect the flag or country April 17
2017 standing on a balcony of the White
House during the Easter egg hunt as the
national anthem plays donald trump
neglects to put his hand over his arch
and has to be reminded to do so by
somebody who knows what the symbolism of
the flag means an immigrant to this
country and one more from a despot
occupying the White House and destroying
the First Amendment Trump February 2nd
if UC Berkley does not allow free speech
and practices violence on innocent
people with a different point of view no
federal funds Trump's hypocrisy is in
its own way perfect the Patriot is not
the cynical amoral bullying insulting
autocratic
magog a hypocrite the patriot is the
American who will risk the public scorn
who will risk the loss of income who
will risk the loss of reputation will
risk the loss of freedom under would be
dictator who exploits the flag in order
to destroy America right now your rights
as an African American as a liberal
American as a conservative American as
an American are being defended not by
the president where the Senators nor the
congressmen but by LeBron James and
Richard Sherman and Colin Kaepernick and
a kid named bruce maxwell that was him
the first baseball player to take a knee
with his teammate mark Konya being a
real american to not protesting as bruce
maxwell did but supporting his right to
protest
Bruce Maxwell has never played a full
season in Major League Baseball but he
put it all on the line anyway why well
Bruce Maxwell was born on an American
military base in Germany his father is a
career army man and his teammate mark
Kenya has provided you with a way to
support the protest without protesting
kneel and sing sit with hand over heart
or stand next to someone doing either
with your hand on their shoulder these
young men are the Patriots as for the
phonies do not stand for Trump
literally join the athletes do not stand
for the anthem I cherish the flag I
cherish America I cherish patriotism I
caressed the right to protest which
defines my country I cherish my country
Donald Trump has nothing to do with my
country we will no longer stand for him
resist remove peace